ready ah action
[Music]
when we start secret Invasion Nick Fury
has been off planet and Maria Hill has
just really been trying to you know
maintain order but this current threat
is getting out of control five Global
terrorists strikes within the past year
each one played by a different group
it's business as usual that's precisely
what they want you to think
and it comes back having lost whatever
power he had before so we try and solve
things without being too superhuman are
you going to shoot me maybe well
probably
but not right now we get to jump into
Nick Fury's World which is very spy
versus despite the kind of grittiness
the locations the way it feels the way
it's written it's a thriller
Fury we gonna be very careful now I had
to pinch myself many mornings when I
would step on set with Olivia Coleman
Sam Jackson Don Cheadle Emilia Clark Ben
benedir I mean some of my favorite
actors in the world alone at last after
every Marvel film released I would phone
my agent say please can I be in a Marvel
thing I never imagined it would happen
what makes you think you can get him to
speak oh I can be quite persuasive
looking at the MCU to these different
lenses you get to see all these
different sides of the characters so we
get to really sort of dig into who they
are how much do you know about your
security detail
what do you mean how much do I know
about it
this idea of who can you trust that is
really the heart of the show you could
be talking to somebody who have a very
close relationship with and then you
find out that that's not who you thought
it was
[Music]
it becomes sort of a cat and mouse game
that we we build toward to the end of
the show
you can't predict it and you can't
preempt it and you can't fathom it until
it happens I'm Nick Fury even when I'm
out I'm here
[Music]
oh